hello Ash Billy Bug entertainment what's
going on sorry I had some technical
difficulties trying to make it work
right now I think it's all up and
running had a little bit of
uh Tech
issues everything seems to be working
though can y'all hear
me I'm excited I'm still
sick I apologize if I'm still coughing a
lot I am still sick so that's
fun yeah I've been sick for like two two
weeks now almost three weeks
now still sick I
don't don't know what's going on but I'm
excited for tonight's episode I
um man yeah I'm really excited for
tonight's episode I think it's going to
be uh I think it's gonna be really great
I'm have one light that's not connected
to my internet there it is Boom all
right what's going on
everybody
yeah this is
um I think this is the episode I haven't
seen this episode I haven't seen this
episode or or the last episode and I'm
still holding true to my theory that
Loki is going to become he who remains
not like a literal King variant but I
think he's going to take over the
TVA and
um I think this is the episode where we
see like the the backstory of a lot of
people like we see Mobius working at uh
piranha Power Sports so I'm really
excited for that Mr Anderson what's
going on welcome welcome welcome thanks
for being
here what's going on everybody uh lowkey
comes out in about 14 minutes actually
that reminds
me let me get all that set
up open up the Disney plus and
whatnot I'm so glad I just can't express
how happy I am that it comes out at 6
pm. pm. Pacific Time now like it's so
much better and I'm sick still so if I
if I was you
know if I if I was still this sick and
it you know came out at 2
am yeah oh thanks TR Galaxy 2K
appreciate
that when are the lokis going to kiss
that's actually really funny but
insanely accurate statement which is
which makes it funny when are the lokis
going to kiss yeah I know I'm imagining
they I don't you think it's in the next
episode I don't know syvia hasn't really
come around much yet to to Loki
yeah usbekistan
usbekistan I've never even heard of that
where's that let me look that up but
thank you I appreciate that where is
that Central Asia okay oh okay yeah yeah
yeah so you're by Kazakhstan a little
bit south of it cool thanks for being I
appreciate
that uh
yes
sorry it sounds like uh so it sounds
like Downey has like already agreed to
come
back maybe he and and possibly has
already signed up hello Deputy 1024
your icon
changed is that copper is that a picture
of copper that's a dog
where's the where's the
deputy Alexander Sullivan what's
something I want to see happen in Loki
for series ends uh I'd like to see more
Kang variants you know oh I'd like to
see
something from Another Universe you know
like a Kang arising on a branch timeline
or something like that you know um
but
if they you know we the recent Variety
article said that they might you know
swap him out with doom which I don't I
don't know I feel like we're too deep I
feel like we're too deep and I don't
know if he's innocent or not but from
what his lawyers say Jonathan major it
sounds like he's got substantial
evidence to prove he's innocent that you
know so if it's looking like he's
goingon to be innocent then why move
away from Kang I think we're already set
up pretty well and I would I would hate
for Dr Doom to come in kind of like in
the last you know like the last quarter
and then and then go away like they if
they did that they'd have to keep uh
Doom for the next Saga you can't just
have that and I'm go away Billy Bug
entertainment thank you yes Echo trailer
tomorrow that's what I hear that's what
I hear I'm going to look out for that
um since I'm pretty sick right
now I'm not sure I'll get out of
breakdown tonight because my breakdowns
before they they were done ahead of time
because I got the episodes ear
so tonight I'll probably take some time
to just go over episode five I'll
probably watch it a couple more times
after we watch it together and then I'll
do a couple different videos on it like
I've been doing I actually prefer what
I've been doing I don't know if you guys
do I like making separate videos about
specific topics of each episode rather
than just a full-on
breakdown
um I don't know I'm more entertained
that way I don't know how y'all feel
about it
so yeah yeah far Shad yeah I have no
idea what's going to happen I mean I
I I think I do just from like Gathering
all the information from the first four
episodes and a little bit of insight
information you know
I I called Kang in Loki season one I
don't know if anyone was here for the
watch parties for Loki season 1 but you
know from the very beginning I think in
like let me
how do I how would
I let me go let me search real quick
because I believe in my very first video
Loki episode one breakdown Cosmic Wonder
never actually searched like this
before yeah so in my very how do I show
this how do I show
this yeah you can kind of see it
there in my very first break down of
Loki season 1 right here oh you can't
really see
it come on I literally put I literally
put Kang Kang is coming on the on my
thumbnail oh no don't play that was Loki
episode one breakdown so that was like a
fun time for me we were talking about
all the theories and stuff because I I
just felt like that's what was going to
happen and Kang eventually came and I'm
like
dang um so I feel like I've got a good
grasp on kind of predicting what's going
to happen just based off of comics and
stuff like
that but I think Loki takes over the TVA
because I think that's the most logical
thing to actually take play storywise
like I think that would be the most
logical thing to do and then you know
one thing I actually am pretty uncertain
about is Loki and sylv's relationship
I'm actually kind of uncertain about
that I hope they stay together I I don't
know but something I would love to see I
would love to see more variants of Kang
I I really would I really really would
uh hold on I think I missed some super
chat okay got that that got
that uh Ray M thanks for Super Chat hope
we learn about different timelines
Dimensions yes you know that is
something they haven't really fully
explained yet you know
um and and it's and it's funny because
like I say things and then people try to
dispute me sometimes online and I'm like
you can't dispute me because we don't
know the actual answer so it's so funny
like and I enjoy just conversations
about things I don't I don't ever really
get heated unless someone insults me but
I'm very capable of having a
conversation with somebody that has
opposing views of me to hear their side
but it's when you start insulting people
and saying they're stupid uh is where I
I'm like okay this you're never gonna
like have a good conversation with
somebody who's insulting you and vice
versa but um
the time thing is you know are the
different branch timelines different
universes or are they all in the same
universe but different time points and
parallel timelines but does parallel
timelines mean parallel universes you
know it it's I feel it's something they
really do actually need to explain to us
I interpret it as the different
timelines are indeed different universes
right because they're not because they
go parallel with the sacred timeline so
you can't just go back in time to visit
a branch timeline that's not how it
works so to me they are separate
universes that's it just makes the most
sense to me Sean Payton thanks for that
big Super Chat man appreciate that I'm
thoroughly enjoying the show hope it
sticks The Landing worried about mul
Saga great ideas to have Clear Vision
what's going on you know I agree and I I
think I said this in my review excuse me
of um the very first two or four
episodes that I saw I said you know it's
great and I hope they stick to Landing
so I I was thinking the exact same thing
as you because it would be a shame if
they they didn't
but who did we hear from Recently like
one of the writers or producers of the
show who just said or the
fil one of the film guys I think
maybe hello there sorry my headset died
real quick had to plug it
in
um yeah uh I think between Loki the
finale of Loki and Deadpool 3 and
perhaps King Dynasty I think we we
should right in theory we should have a
really good idea of what's going on we
should I don't know if we will but I
hope they stick the landing and I and I
I have faith in Marvel I know a lot is
coming out
recently but you know I said this in my
video today a lot of what they
did a a lot of what Marvel Studios did
starting phase 4 was so new to them like
there there's always going to be
learning curve when you're doing
something new and I hope that eventually
we just get past that learning curve and
and and they just you know start to
crush it again so what's up Valeria
Valdez what's going on Ogo Parker yes
five more minutes let me uh I got to
pull it up on my phone because that's
how I watch the chat once we're watching
the actual excuse me oh Marvel just came
out with an actual
clip oh and it's a clip we haven't seen
I'm not going to watch it I I I'm not
going to watch it we're gon we're going
to
wait we're GNA wait we're GNA wait yeah
um Matt Connors I have low expectations
for the Marvels you know honestly I
don't think it's going to be a terrible
movie but not going to lie like having
low expectations going into it will
probably make it a more enjoyable movie
because I actually genuinely believe
that it's going to be a decent movie I I
really do I think it's got potential um
I don't think it's going to be as
bad as everyone thinks it is unless
you're one of those really like I hate
the MCU you know if you're you know if
you feel that way then you're probably
not going to like the show and or movie
and that's just you know that's what it
is that's your opinion but um I think
it's going to be decent I actually think
it's going to be pretty good but I'm
like you I'm trying to lower my
expectations going in excuse
me you think spider versus connected to
Loki and the overall MCU
AV I would love for that to be the case
and I think there's a decent chance that
that could be the case and the only
reason I don't want to dive all in and
say Yes is because of Sony you know
um yeah we all know how how sticklers
how much of sticklers they are see you
Darkness on the Wind see y uh Emanuel
and uh so I'm probably not going to see
the Marvels ahead of time because I am
sick I was supposed to go to La this
week
I'm not trying to get people sick on the
plane I'm not trying to get people sick
you know I was supposed to go to
BlizzCon this weekend too um and the mar
I'm supposed to see the Marvels on
Tuesday I'm not going to go I'm sick I'm
not trying I'm not trying to get other
people sick and I'm trying to get better
myself so I'm just going to see it when
it comes
out or maybe they because i' that's a
lie I have been sent a screener for a
movie I've been sent Black Widow cuz
that didn't come out in theaters maybe I
can talk to Marvel L can send me a
screener but typically for the big
movies like this they just show
screenings in New York and la so yeah
Sean we need a Mobius on a jet ski it
has been set up he works at a jet ski
place but I don't want that variant
still living on the timeline to write it
I want the Mobius we know to write it
you know what I mean like because he has
no recollection of writing the jet ski
before but he loves them I don't want
the guy who sells them and already knows
what it's like I want our
Mobius to uh
to yeah to write it thank you guys I
appreciate that appreciate everybody
telling me uh to to to get better I
really appreciate that um loading that's
and that's your opinion man and and I'm
not going to say that they they've
really
like they've done a great job with them
you know what I mean they've some have
been good but some have been crap you
know I'm not going to sit there and deny
that okay um how did I do that stopwatch
Mr Anders stopwatch
[Music]
uh what would Shock Me The Proud
Canadian o
um I think if we got like a a cameo from
somebody we weren't expecting I think
that's what would shock me the most
um you know like if we found out
somebody was playing Kang and there's
someone above him like if Dr Doom was
like Kang's my puppet you know what I
mean that that would that would honestly
Shock Me Or Another or wasn't there like
a thing that said like Sylvia was
actually in charge of the TVA the entire
time that would Shock Me beak gen V but
finale will ah be thanks for that super
chat I have not watched it actually I
have not watched it I sometimes I do get
really like I don't it's about to start
it is starting now so hold on let me uh
um I got this
up let me pull up Disney
plus I'm
refreshing I mean yeah if the Thor Cameo
comes all right guys you ready because
I'm about to start this in five four
three two
one please don't pause sometimes it
pauses it paused hold on on hold on hold
on
refreshing please don't
pause okay we good uh
two I'm just going to start this I
actually can't
tell eight nine okay I gotta stop this
for just like just a second 12 13 boom
there we go oh I don't hear anything oh
that's not good hold
on
uh why don't I hear
anything I don't hear anything I hear
stuff now okay we're
good all right we are doing the recap we
always watch the recap so we're in it
right now
um this is where I'm at right now we're
doing the
recap
so
cool Loki's really GNA have to Ho it
then I loved I loved how Mobius was just
so afraid of losing his
skin all right I'm I'm you willum me be
more quiet this time because I oh hold
on let me pull it up on my phone okay
okay
okay all
right all right we are we are at the
Marvel intro right here let going
through we are a minute and 24 seconds
into it and let's find out what happens
how they live where my theories right
where your theor is
right I'm G to talk a little uh less
this time because you know I don't know
what's going to happen
so everything looks good on
here let's do
it all right so everything's exploded
exp looing
now oh did they not blow up they didn't
blow up oh Loki's gonna be back in time
somehow
right I bet you he's back in
time and he he's stuck in Ora boros like
it's never
ending yep
he somehow
survived did he who remains save him
that's my
question and the time Lim is just in the
background interesting
yeah he must have time slipped Ogo
that's what I was thinking like he time
slipped right away they thought they
stopped the time slipping
though wait so he's in the TVA right now
and no one's in the
TVA fail safe mode oh he's glitch yeah
he's time slipping again fail safe mode
initiated what is
that hey Aaron
we're three minutes into it okay so he's
time
glitching but how did he start time
glitching again all of a sudden because
of the device because the time that got
destroyed
maybe oh that's Loki he's looking at
himself are these different is he is he
slipping out of time too cuz he just did
not he didn't end up in the same spot or
did the TVA
change this has to be controlled he who
remains had to have controlled the time
slipping that's so that's too perfect
they sto the time slipping he hadn't
time slipped in a while and then all of
a sudden he time slip right before he
dies that's got to be intentional I'm
going to I'm going to say that's
intentional
somehow maybe Mr Anderson maybe that's
maybe that's what it is I wouldn't be
surprised if a he oh he just saw himself
look at
that he just that's
cool oh everything is just
spaghettification everything Aaron no
I'm not feeling better hey Jason welcome
oh my gosh this is insane is he about to
just is he about to no he time slipped
oh no that's not what I meant to
do fail safe mode initiated what is
that does it just get rid of
it oh I like this though I didn't really
see that that
coming
ah Tasha yeah just keep refreshing I had
actually refreshed a couple times in the
beginning as well oh this is Casey is he
is it going to be Casey and G because we
saw that scene in the in one of the
trailers gal Ragnarok I don't know what
that
is it's really dark I can't were we
supposed to know who that is this is
going to be Casey though yep he's
sleeping on the
floor
yikes he's been is he oh look at that
wow oh there are lots of other
people
so he's escaping from jail or Casey
was a criminal before I mean it doesn't
ultimately matter his memory was erased
he seems to be a good guy
now hey thanks Brennon appreciate
that are they on a boat is that what
that noise was no they're in a
prison oh they're they're
by is that alcatra Branch timeline 1962
that's
Alcatraz no no no I think they're on
alcatra
oh it's so dark I can't really
see
how did Loki get
there it is
alcatra thank you thuka still sick but
still
so this is a branch timeline so it
might dang that's so cool th this might
oh he got him caught
damn maybe oh and he's back at
McDonald's see these places are so
specific why is he time slipping to
everyone he knows that's why I think it
it's kind of controlled like cuz why
isn't he just time slip like why didn't
he time slip in my room right now like
it it's so
specific New York New York oh look it's
under
B15 a branch
timeline
uh it is out Nano we are watching it
right now
look so Hunter
B15 and then see Loki is specifically
showing up to these places of people
that he knows so why like why is it so
specific
yeah yeah look at him go look at him go
it's not really on it I can obviously
tell he's not in the water look at
him
yes
oh let at him
go
damn he just wants everyone to have jet
skis did they say his name was
Don I I got I gotta see him in the water
and I gotta see I gotta see not his
variant on a branch timeline I have to
see him the Mobius we know I need him on
a jet ski in the water with Loki on his
back exactly Ogo I need our
variant
ATV a single
dead Jason I've been I've been chugging
emergency man I have
man and who's
this Pasadena California which show me
your
face oh is it
OB it's
OB oh that's
him
oh a poor
OB he's just trying to get his he's just
trying to get his book
read oh that's a good point Bethany why
are all of these in California
interesting maybe Kang was there and he
took them all from a singular location
maybe he abducted all of California in a
timeline this is kind of making me think
a little less that OB oh my gosh is that
that's the same place
look so that place becomes the TVA does
California become the
TVA
maybe he is time slipping in the TVA in
the past but in in in or in the in the
present maybe he still is in the TVA
just hasn't been built
yet he's still in the same space though
he's not traveling through space he's
just traveling through time and this is
a time where the TVA has not been built
yet
wow
that becomes the this this place becomes
the TVA in the future it just hasn't
been built
yet it's not a
replica it's not a replica it becomes it
later
on
uh
yeah you
do exactly
exactly
PB James love
it oh I like that I like
that
The Ghost and Molly McGee what's
up
no but why is he himself a temp pad I
need to know why
speaking of the why I need to know
[Laughter]
why
he's trying to contort his body
dang this is
awesome
science
he's trying to like get it out of
him
I think he's about to explain what I
think is
happening
o oh he has a TVA he has a t TVA guy
book in his pocket he has a TVA guy book
in his pocket give it to him
yes he does he does come on you have it
yep look at that
awesome I
did I am going to write a book that's
hilarious and then
he he did what he did needed to do and
then he time slipped again is that how
it
works o whose house is this this
Mobius it's
Mobius
[Laughter]
poor
guy I stole
them oh no do his kids
suck oh I think his kids suck
[Laughter]
suck small
victories
oh he had has him
himself
he's like
obious
oh he built it
already oh my
gosh
oh is he going back in time they just
went back in time so they can prove it
to
him so he could show
him but it's it's not
him what's up Jacob how's it going I
hope you found a good Community with
us it's too high H that's
funny
I sell jety
man yeah he's going to see
himself
yep so it's like he's not even
gone that's that's
crazy
all of existence is in danger I don't
care
Mobius so is Loki actually the reason
why everybody has called all of their
names it's pretty cool name that's
really cool Jacob I'm glad you found
that with those people and with us I'm
glad I'm glad you're
here man Obie saving the day and oh and
then
Casey
I still want to know why Obie's
place because Obi builds the TVA from
his Warehouse is that how it
works EG Nick Noob what's going on yeah
I'm actually really liking this episode
I think it's really cool I like the
deeper stuff so that's this is kind of
like this making my brain
think Loki's totally gonna take over the
TVA though he he's totally gonna take
over the
TVA he has to that is his glorious
purpose to literally protect the entire
Multiverse that's got to be what it
is he's gonna steal it
this place this place becomes a TVA
that's pretty crazy and then I don't
know how they get it outside of space
but that's crazy
oh
Sylvie is he gonna get Sylvie from a
different no maybe yeah this is the
past where did she yeah who
knows oh I'm so
curious oh oh my gosh it's it's getting
pruned it's going away it's spaghetti
fying
the bag it's
gone I don't think they need Ren Slayer
I know they need Sylvie though because
Sylvie was there right before it
exploded
[Music]
no no get in the time
door
no they're not it's not the same
people
this is
of course she doesn't why would she
care it's not going to
matter if everything dies it doesn't
matter
well we'll see inedible Hulk will see
how it
ends
I mean the TVA kind of needs to exist
for you know
existence it's a little less
selfish but they're
not as the head of the TVA buddy what's
going on Mr movie Madness what's going
on
okay but he doesn't even need you to
leave he just needs you in a room for
the temporal
Aura come on
Loki just grab her she's not
even
Bank
fault
is he trying to sell a jet
ski he's trying to sell a jet
ski
oh
is it sylv and they're going to sh he's
going to Care again for some
reason yeah that's
Sylvia
yeah that's
funny does she have the temp pet still
that bracelet is not the temp
bed well thank you Mr movie Madness I'm
glad you
have hey Rafi what's going
on okay I'm going to need some stuff to
happen
please
did
oh yeah I'm not sure
she
realizes what's at stake and I'm
surprised Loki didn't tell her that
either look everything's just going to
go to
hell everything's
yeah that's what I'm confused about like
Loki how did you not tell her that like
her universe is going to be destroyed
too
like and she just has no idea because
she
I mean kudos to you dude for trying to
save her even in that moment when you
have no idea what's going on good for
you
bro all right syv take out the temp pad
go find Loki let's do
this
it's kind of making me sick because I'm
a little sick
already all right Sylvie bust out the
tin pad find
Loki is she going away too no she's not
affected yep there it is there's the
temp
pad now you understand it only took an
entire universe being destroyed for you
to understand
for
said you're
not you're
not you're not the whole the whole mly
verse is going to be
destroyed
exactly
yes did Casey take the damn Tim
pad
where would he have put it oh snap
oh you get the hell out of there
bro it was a what friction problem
no that was hard to
watch we're watching end game all over
again Sylvie
to
oh fiction
problem he just went back in
time
he's finally controlling
it exactly
Ogo
[Music]
good
how
who yes oh finally oh is there a post
credit oh wait there's a post credit no
no is there not is what is
this or is this just
a wait is this a little post credit or
not am I did I
no no it's not
okay
interesting wow okay so
I actually enjoyed that episode I like
the the deeper ons I do agree it could
have been done a little bit
faster but now I'm
like so now I'm really wondering what's
going to
happen in the last episode and I hope
it's long
because he's obviously going to fix he's
obviously going to keep going back in
time and figure it out until until
Victor doesn't die until you know the
loom is
fixed so what ha like what happens in
the last episode how does it end what
does it set up I think it ends with Loki
realizing that his place is there with
the
TVA the god of the stories is God of
stories is accurate
it's it's him playing God like she said
right but he's not gonna I don't think
he's gonna go
back like all the way
back I think he can only go back to to
his variants as well right
so he can only like time glitch time
slip to other versions of himself in the
past right
so
so he can't rewrite the entire history
of the TVA because he was not there for
the entire history of the TVA right so
you can't do that
unfortunately no thanks oo I appreciate
that thank you that this generous Super
Chat thank you very much really really
appreciate it yeah
um so he can't he can only go back to
himself which means
his which means him going back in time
is limited to the times that he was
actually at the
tbaa so I don't think they're gonna go I
mean
maybe maybe he maybe they might revisit
season 1 maybe it isn't about fixing the
time loon but fixing other things
that happened before that
but I think the what I what I'm going to
say is the most obvious answer here is I
think he goes back and and we saw this
in the trailers a little bit you know he
says again a few times in the in some
trailers that we've seen you know
um I think the obvious answer is he he
just keeps going again and again until
he fix until he finds out a way to
actually fix the time Loom and then from
there it's up to the TVA to monitor the
timelines and make sure no evil variant
of Kang comes to place and I think
that's where Loki comes in that's that's
I've been saying this from the beginning
Loki's glorious purpose is to take over
the
TVA that's what I think is is going to
happen I I really do I think this is I
think this is how it ends Loki they
decide Loki is the one
who Loki is the one who you know has
to rule everything which is crazy you
know
like Loki literally has to rule the
Multiverse like literally
everything
right that's how it ends Loki is
Loki takes control of the Multiverse
this is how he gets involved with Secret
Wars this is how the
TVA gets involved in Deadpool 3 this is
how I gotta make a note I gotta make a
note in my head for the breakdown hold
on okay sorry
um I think I think ultimately what's
going to happen in secret Wars hi
rocket I think ultimately everything
that happens in secret Wars is going to
be orchestrated and led bye
Loki I agree Mr Anderson this is
definitely the biggest MCU character Arc
ever and I'm glad it's Loki I'm glad
it's Tom hedson because he's awesome and
the character is
awesome but th this is this is it this
is this is literally it's just going to
go straight into it's literally going to
go straight into de Deadpool 3 like
straight into Deadpool 3 it's going to
go
into we can't this is how it happens
they can't prune the timelines because
that's not what it's about right it's
it's
about giving people the their free
choice the free will but you have to
monitor it because kangs are going to
come so they're going to open up they're
going to make it to where the loom can
handle all the timelines and so we're
going to have this huge Multiverse and
the multiversal war is going to start
and Loki being in charge of the TBA and
knowing about the Avengers and and you
know all the superheroes the TVA goes to
different
universes
they assemble the multiversal Avengers
team and that is Secret Wars and that's
where we get Hugh Jackman Wolverine Toby
McGuire Spider-Man Tom Holland
Spider-Man Loki as the god of Mischief
Thor you know that that's this is how
literally everything comes together
because of Loki th this
is this I
is really just a great Arc for
Loki if it really is for that ends like
that and can you
imagine can you imagine the interaction
between like Thor and Loki after all of
this and and like Thor realizes like
what Loki did like not only is he good
but he saved the entire
Multiverse yeah Matthew I've been saying
that uh you know I think he who remains
is behind this somehow I re I really do
I really think he who remains could
still be behind this you know I
think
yeah but I think this is exactly
what
yeah I think this is
uh I think this is it I think it the
next episode ends with Loki ruling the
TVA and then you go into Deadpool 3 and
the TVA assembles The multiversal
Avengers team and there you
go there we
go that's what it
is it's interesting so one of the
biggest things though
is like how how is Loki time slip
slipping like why he wasn't before was
it really him being kicked out kicked
through a a Time door controlled by he
who remains his temp pad like that was
probably part of of he who remains his
plan
right Sylvie had the temp pad maybe he
made sure she got it she kicked him
through a door he knew it was going to
set up the time slipping and he knew
look he had to time slip because he
would have to go back in time and fix
the TVA and that way the only question
is why would he who remains at the end
of lucki season 1 want there to be a
Multiverse because he had narrowed it
down to just one sacred timeline one
universe
so so why would he who remains want that
that's the question
that's a question be why would he want
the Multiverse does he want is he
bored it's kind of stupid you know
reason but
like
huh um I'm not finding the comment above
what I'm not seeing it
Jason
Wolverine oh Galaxy gig's not the
biggest fan huh yeah I can see how some
people went out like this episode it's
definitely
slower and relieves that put him in
charge relives put in charge on I don't
know I do think they're going to revisit
he who remains
yeah I think that's the key
question that's the key question I
think how is Loki time slipping and I
think videos for bab tell yeah that's
what we've been talking about ly the got
up stories I think that is basically the
arc that they're
doing I but I think it I I I literally
think I really think it is controlled by
he who
[Music]
remains Loki's Gonna Roll the TVA and
he's going to be the most powerful
person in the entire Multiverse until
Kang and his variants go up against him
and what's
interesting is you would imagine that
some of the variants of Kang like like
uh
um the trio of Kings wow that took me so
long to get out uh the the Council of
Kings the trio of Kings like you have to
imagine that they have some sort of
working knowledge of how the TVA works
right I
mean the V some variant of King have to
know that so I wonder how easily the you
know the Council of Kings I wonder how
easily they could like take down the TV
if they wanted to right do they have a
misit of their own that could go into TV
you know it's it's it's interesting
because Loki isn't a variant of Kang and
if if he who remains really
did put him
there for a
reason those are the two questions how
why and how are Loki time is Loki time
slipping right like
how
H yeah that was pretty funny
right thanks for that Super Chat uh
tddp 574 yeah that was a that was funny
I noticed that too with Loki and Sylvie
um yeah I'm I'm I'm on that
too
um
videos for B toos I'm on that two I'm on
that two where he who remains said see
you soon I've talked about that in a
bunch of videos where I I think he meant
that literally I don't think he meant
like hey my variants are coming after
you no I think he meant himself I think
it's part of his plan because like why
would he why would he tell the truth
right that's the question we have to ask
like I think it I think at at the end of
looky season one where they're talking
to him and it's all like well why would
he lie he's done no this this is part of
his plan this is totally part of his
plan so yeah I I I do think Loki is the
most powerful character now he can
control his time slipping he's going to
do that over and over again until they
figure out some type of way to fix the
time Loom because you know we heard that
in one of the vid in one of the
trailers we heard Loki see him go up to
OB and ask what could we have done
differently so he's just going to
basically keep asking and asking that
they're going to add to it add to it
fail fail fail until eventually it
works
yeah uh ebony D young um you know I
actually really think this is gonna
end I think this is going to end with
Loki rolling the TVA and then I think
Loki is going to be the person
that assembles the Multiverse Avengers
team like I I really think that's what
it
is
I do think they're going to revisit he
who remains back in
time I
do what's up
Leon how does God of stories L TI to
secret Warriors I mean it really really
just kind of depends on what direction
they they take
it wait hold on keep people keep
mentioning this in credits let me go
back because that's I thought we were
referencing that other point when looki
and Sylvie were at the bar together but
we're talking about something else here
I
guess is it at the very end like where
where where is it what did I
miss somebody tell somebody time stamp
it for
me because I'm I'm missing it I'm not
I'm not finding
it I don't am I missing it guys because
I don't see it oh it's
loud no keep watching
yeah what's interesting is you could go
that way and
like you could say now that Loki created
the
TVA but but he didn't so that's that's
the thing is like this is
all it's all kind of happening in
another Branch timeline as weird as that
sounds you know uh
um because Loki didn't create the TVA
and it was it also seemed really weird
when OB said that he learned everything
from Victor timley because that doesn't
make sense either you know because we
know that he who remains made the TVA
they even showed us like you know a
brief clip of
um uh of Kang with Ren Slayer after you
know the war the TVA was already created
like he who remains created the TVA so
it's really
interesting it's it's really interesting
that they say things like that that you
know OB said he learned everything from
Victor timley that uh now we can maybe
say that you know Loki kind of
inadvertently created the TVA now uh I
don't think that's I don't think that's
true I think it just goes right into
Deadpool
3 can somebody tell me the the the coin
thing at the end some people keep
talking about some little post credit
thing
yeah there was a voice at the
end uh yeah Ogo it it's basically yeah
next episode is basically going to be
Groundhogs
Day try fail try fail try fail try fail
till eventually they figure out exactly
how to fix the time Loom that's all
that's what's going to be so we could
pretty much
assume we know a decent amount of what
the next episode is going to be the only
questions that we have right now because
okay basically's going to go like this
he's going to go back he's going to say
hey let's fix it and they're going to
fail just like they
did last episode not this episode last
episode and then he's just going to say
okay well what did we get wrong before
you know it all dies
and OB is going to either know or not
know and then he's going to slip back
say hey this is what we did wrong last
time because they're going to know
basically they're just it's it's kind of
funny because basically if you think
about it
um like OB Sylvie Mobius all of them are
basically just going to be like sitting
there and Loki is's just going to go
away come back go away come back go away
come back because he's going to keep
coming back in time and basically he's
gonna he's going to do that until he
says all right it finally worked this is
what we do well I guess you after it
finally worked he wouldn't have to go
back in time again
so until then that's basically what's
going to happen
so yeah so that's that's that's how it
ends or that that's how the next episode
goes
um they're gonna fix the time Loom and
then
eventually they're going to have to talk
about what that means for the future
going forward how to prevent Kang the
Conqueror which I I think is just going
to
be them
stating
hey we we have to monitor it and if a
variant of he who remains comes around
we're just gonna have to kind of kill
him KS Mughal interesting thought he
remains didn't make the TVA I think Kang
set it in motion so that TVA is created
but Loki creates it see I don't know
man I don't know I I
think I still think he who remains
really did create the TVA and there's
there's a lot
of I want to say misdirect in in this I
I really do I want to say there's a lot
of misdirect because they're they're
making it seem almost like you know OB
created the TVA and he could only do it
with the help of Victor timley but you
know how does that make sense because
Victor timley is a branched King the
Conqueror he's not he's not he who
remains he's not he who remains he who
remains was born in the 31st Century he
lived the 31st
Century Alex that's a good point thanks
for that Super Chat yeah maybe this is a
part of he remains' plan to really show
Loki that it's him hey you're you are
the successor of the TVA maybe yeah
maybe it's not so malicious maybe it's
not maybe it's not
evil what yeah what if he Ms actually
wasn't doing this to be evil what if he
was specifically doing it what if
actually that's a good point what if he
was telling the truth what if he really
was
saying
hey you're the only person that could
take my place and what if he's doing all
of this he orchestrated all this to show
Loki this is how it has to
[Music]
be
yeah he he said a beon to myself but
then he said I harnessed the power of
aath which means he was there at that
time I mean
yeah unless this
unless and also at the same time he uh
Victor timley even said he didn't have
the technology to create you know all
the stuff he didn't have the technology
to create the TVA and even OB
said even OB said something about it
like you know he was he was an
inventor who didn't have the technology
he
needed
[Music]
so
yeah I don't know I'm I'm trying to
think trying to think about the story of
he who remains that that's
honestly that's the big question right
now is because we know what's going to
happen next episode we know you know
it's a ora boros it's a snake eating
itself you know it it's a it's a loop
it's Groundhog's Day Loki is going to go
back in time as many times as needed so
where he can fix the time Loom but then
that's the question what happens after
that we we know that TVA is going to be
a part of Deadpool 3 so the TVA is not
going anywhere we know that the
Multiverse is going to be a part of
Deadpool 3 secret Wars the
Marvels so they're not going to go back
to one main sacred timeline it's going
to remain a bunch of different branch
timelines they fix the time looms to
where it can hold all of the timelines
in it and then Loki rules it with his
friends that's what he wants right he
wants to be with his friends so Loki
rules it with his
friends and then he assembles The
multiversal Avengers team to take care
of the Council of Kings because those
are that's the big problem that's the
big problem what is going to stop
everybody having free will Kang's ruling
the Multiverse right doing what they
want with it so of course Loki has to go
up against the Council of Kings that's
that's it that's Secret Wars that is
literally Secret Wars it's Loki
assembling a Multiverse multiversal
Avengers team from a lot of different
universes the TVA goes to these
universes grabs the best heroes puts
them all in one place and they go and
they fight all the variant of kings that
is literally Secret Wars that is
literally Deadpool 3 and Secret
Wars because Loki's going to rule the
TVA but King the Conqueror is going to
want to destroy the TVA or take over it
himself whoever Prime King is or the
three prime Kings uh because they want
to rule the Multiverse like they're
doing and remember they've already
started doing all this stuff we saw that
in the post credit for Quantum Mania he
said the Avengers are going to undo
everything you know that we've done so
far yeah exactly unicorns and
strawberries I that's what I mentioned
before too he who remains gave like made
sure Sylvie got that temp pad so when he
Loki got kicked through he would time
slip because it was he who remains his
tin pad and that tin pad is
different because the TVA exists outside
of space and time for everybody that's
why even OB said it's not possible but
it is for Kang or he who remains because
he is the one who who
knew how time worked he knows how time
works right everybody else can control
time using the technology that was
created but Kang or he remains actually
knows how time itself works so his his
temp pad uh is very different and I
think that's I think
that's how and why Loki is time
slipping yeah I I think it could be I I
do think he who remains orchestrated
this but I'm still having I'm still
questioning why if he was already ruling
everything if he was already ruling
everything and no evil variants were
fighting him why would he need to kind
of reset
it hey Bradley thanks for Super Chat
yeah I don't know I don't I don't think
so but it but it's possible apparently
we'll find out next
episode yeah uh nkum
nkum Loki is pretty op right now with
his ability to time slip yeah
yeah uh Kang Dynasty is gonna gonna be
about our Earth specifically fighting
one variant of King uh George georgees
yeah that's
honestly what what I'm thinking did he
who remains just get bored and now he
wants to try to win another multiversal
War like so he needed Loki to to Branch
but why would he need Loki to do all
that he could have
just he could have just branched the
timelines
himself I agree that they shouldn't um
move from
Kang I don't I don't think they should I
think
I think they should keep King it's set
up really well right now everything's
set up really well
yeah what is
it people keep people keep trying to
tell me that there's some in credit
thing but I'm not finding it someone Tim
stamp it for me
please because I'm not finding it
it's like right what are you saying
right
before season two episode
five Jonathan granadas where Bay at I am
not really sure what you're talking
about to be perfectly honest
uh
Aaron is Kang going to really be
replaced
uh I don't think so I don't think it
would be
good I I really don't think it would be
a good idea okay hold on people they
time sa for me thank you very
much all right let me hear oh
no dude this thing is so
glitchy like okay let me
see I don't hear anything at this time
stamp guys
H and now it froze Disney plus is not
having a good time let me try a
different uh
browser I'm not hearing it though 4429
442 okay so 4429 let me look there I
didn't it's being real glitchy for me
it's like freezing and stuff so may
maybe oh okay hold on
yeah you died insert your coin
loser I mean it could just be a
metaphor right like you get another life
but you have to
pay
interesting
yeah I think it is that ziac game that
they were playing
before and it does sound like Brad's
voice here let's go back
to why it dude Disney plus is spazzing
out hey trade talk thanks so much for
that Super Chat what if king of
conqueror
comes comes to the void and with help of
Rona they come out of there and help
defeat all the K King Dynasty they get
to know that he is the real big bad yeah
totally possible
um I'm not I think there's going to be a
Kang variant who's gonna try to take the
TV TVA away from Loki that's what I
think and I think ravona is GNA be a
part of that because raana is she is at
the void right now and yeah you're right
you know what a king shows up and that
King is the person who tries to take
back the TVA and I think it might just
simply be he who remains all part of his
plan yeah freak pull well thanks for the
super chat but I don't know if it's
gonna be dumb ending I I know it's going
to set up a
lot I know it's going to set up a
lot okay Disney plus is like there must
be tons of people watching Loki right
now which is great which is great but
this thing is uh
freaking dang man yeah I Disney plus is
not even moving for me I'm gonna my geez
I'm gonna have to exit the browser let's
try it
again
uh
la la Lan W Lars yeah I don't I I would
hope he's not replaced if he's found
guilty they're going to replace him for
sure thanks Aron see you all right let's
see if I can get Disney plus to work so
I can find this one
spot
okay yeah I think it's just Brad the
post credit is just Brad
wolf uh saying you died insert your coin
loser because of a zaniac game I think I
think that's honestly what it is I I
don't think
uh I don't think it means
anything uh
although uh although
I I don't know Brad's rolling all of
this right like what is he what does he
do in the
next what is he what does he do in the
next episode right does he play any part
in this
huh uh kosal thanks for that Super Chat
what if he who remains molded the
timeline into the into inverse might be
a strip mold and we were trying to get
it back in its original
form oh that's a thought that's a
thought yeah
um I like where I like the direction
you're thinking because that you know
that is the big question is why would he
who
remains wna give it to Loki why would he
want all of this to happen
why would he want all this to happen
right and I actually do like the idea
that he was bored
right I
mean and I and I don't I don't believe
Victor timley is he who remains I really
don't gosh Disney plus really just is
not working is
it come on
man
wow I can't yeah
whatever yeah anyways uh it's not
working but yeah it's just the game guys
the that post credit little reference is
just to the Zodiac game
um uh I don't know if he remains is
going to take it back in King
Dynasty oh Isaac that's a good point
maybe Brad does free Rana from the void
but I think something's going to happen
with raana in the void I think maybe
she'll meet a king variant
there but I still do I still believe
even though I'm not 100% sure why I
still believe this is being orchestrated
by he who remains I think that see you
soon was very literal I think he
literally meant
me myself not a variant will see you
soon but why why did he have to do all
of
this that's yeah I do like the idea some
people are talking about um Avengers
Prime he is kind
of yeah I mean he's not going to be like
the embodiment of every single Avenger
in one person but in a way he you know
he he is doing that he's getting
everybody together I like that idea I
like that idea I also like uh Loki got
of
stories I do like that a
lot uh for many people asking uh no it
is not official that Kang is canceling
their switch into to Doom I actually
think it would be a bad idea to do that
save Doom for later finish with Kang if
Jonathan major is found guilty recast
him it is what it is and move forward
so uh I think he's got a lot of evidence
to prove he's not guilty but of course I
don't know that for sure I hope he's not
guilty you know I hope I hope not he's
phenomenal actor really is hope he
remains
King vgs M thanks for that Super Chat he
who remains is a king and all he wants
is to conquer maybe he had to die to
bring the multivers back thank you for
all your work from Greece oh hey Greece
that's awesome yeah you know that falls
into the whole board thing right um
that's who he is he's a conqueror he's
conquered already and he's bored and now
he doesn't know what to do and he's
tired and he just wants to feel alive
again you know and I think it would be
such an evil villain line if at the end
he's in charge and he takes over and
Loki's just like well why do all of this
and he's like because I was bored like
that would be
such an evil villain thing right it
would be such an evil villain thing to
say just like I was straight up bored
like I was murdering all these timelines
I conquered everything I beat everybody
and then I was chilling and then I got
bored so I messed around again I screwed
around with the
Multiverse billions of lives trillions
of lives because I was bored because I'm
the best and I want to do it again I
want to defeat feed everybody again I
hope that I honestly hope that's what it
is because that's that's villain that's
villain AF right I mean that's
like uh kha Chris now thanks for that
super chat again Loki is a hero already
I I think Loki really is
yeah the real world quoting all yeah I
I I I I like that idea and I I feel like
that would make
sense D Visa that's not a bad point
either
um maybe something with Loki and Sylvie
threw everything off and he he had to
reset it for some
reason maybe but I still think
uh uh I still think he could just do it
because he's just a villain right I I
like when I like when we have villains
who are just evil and they mess with
people like I like it a lot
um where do I see the Council of Kings
coming to this where are they how can
they see the timelines uh if Loki does
gain control of TVA shouldn't he'd be
able to stop them quickly so I think
they might actually have tvas of their
own I think kind of
that Arena place that we saw them at in
the post credit of a Quantum Mania is
their own kind of void right something
outside of space in time which is how
you can see the Multiverse because if we
think about he who remains he created
his Citadel in the void outside of time
well other Kang variants could do that
too right if they're just as smart as he
is or even smarter like they could
create that place as well and that's
kind of the whole point of Kang is you
know he rules time outside of space and
time so we saw Victor timley who's like
you know what is it 18th century 19th
century but but other kings who were
from like the 31st Century like the
original variant was they're way more
advanced and they should be able to
create a place like that no
problem
so
yeah freak pool what did Loki mean it's
not about when how but
who I think it might be about
himself I think it's about I think it's
he can slip back to himself right it's
not
about other people him trying to find
other people or something like that it's
about him being able to basically go
back in time in his own body
right so at any point in time in the
timeline he can go back to himself only
right he can just go back to himself I
think that's what it means but maybe
they'll offer more clarity Samuel Forest
thanks for that Super Chat oh it
disappeared hold on thanks for that
Super Chat will this set up K and King
Dynasty do you think and will will Kang
be in episode 6 also is Loki the
Multiverse Saga Iron
Man hey that's a kind of cool question
at the end there is Loki the the
Multiverse sag of Iron Man I think so
actually
I think so that's uh I never thought
about that before but yeah I think I I
would say that um yes we'll set up King
Dynasty we'll also set up Deadpool 3 and
Secret Wars actually more than it sets
up King Dynasty probably um what was
your other question I hope I know Victor
Tim Le is in the next episode and I
really hope some variant of Kang whether
T who remains or somebody comes in uh I
think they need to for it to be a really
good ending and
yeah I think Loki can only jump to
himself in previous points in
time maybe that's what he meant
so uh I don't know if this new power is
going to be with Loki
so yeah and at the but at the same time
they kind of said like Loki is a temp
pet
himself so when he said who is he maybe
he's talking about he who
remains I don't know that's a that's
that's the it's still the big question
I'm gonna have to ponder it over some
more I'm have to really think about it
just think
about
why why would he who remains do this I
can under I I I I think I get every
everything
everything besides
that uh beat Beatles Because that that
is what that's the Paradox of it right
that's the time Loop that's just you
know what happened first they even
mentioned that rocket hi what Jen doing
you hungry I'll feed Jen just a bit
um they talk about it you know which
came first the it's kind of like the
chicken or the egg which came
first you know so we don't really have
an answer for that thanks for those
Super Chat bgsm what if you wanted to
bring all the other kings back to be
defeated from Avengers and at the end
come to fight both remaining weaked
sides yeah I mean totally you know there
is a possibility
that
Loki and other
Avengers were getting too close to Kang
so he needed the Multiverse to open up
again so the other King barant could
come and so they could defeat him maybe
you know what maybe he who remains is
working with the Kang counsil or wanted
the K counsil and that's why he had to
do that to get the variants
back maybe he wanted to well no he
already dominated
everything I'm thinking maybe he wanted
more but he already
won we already won
so so yeah but all right guys I'm going
to jump off cuz I've been sick for a
while and I need to get some rest
tomorrow I'm going to put out a couple
videos on this hopefully we get some
good theories hopefully I can answer
some questions in these videos uh Poncho
with thank you for that super chat with
Loki not only slipping through time but
space well could this connect to across
spider at all see on mil slips too you
know I think a lot of us have been
thinking that for a while now and I
would really love for it to be true um I
would really love for it to be true but
I don't know and the only reason know is
because of the whole Sony Marvel thing I
don't I don't know they're playing nice
with each other right now you know what
I mean like I don't know how well it's
uh I don't know how well it's
doing
so the metal Warrior that's actually a
good point you know what if he lied
about the war and everything like that I
don't
know yeah you know I think I think next
episode better answer our questions I
hope it I hope it does uh let's stop
with the super chats guys cuz I'm going
to get off I don't want to miss any they
are a little bit delayed so I don't want
uh someone to Super Chat and then me get
off um I think what's I think what's
incredible is is if you think back to
the start of Loki as a villain and you
and you just think about it now like
he's such a great character his story
arc is amazing he's a hero now he's
literally going to SA the entire
Multiverse like
literally
like yeah and and I think and that's a
good point Loki is carrying MC on his
back yeah right now he's the greatest
thing this happened in a while but
so yeah but anyways all right guys I'm
going to jump off uh look out for my
videos tomorrow they're not going to
come out tonight because I I didn't get
this one in advance I never saw this one
until you know an hour ago or whatever
um so I'm going to take my time go
through it watch it again Etc and do
some videos on it tomorrow so got for
those um thank you to everybody for
stopping by today really appreciate it
I'm really excited for the next episode
I hope to see you all back here next
week so we can talk about it again um
yeah it's going to be crazy exciting I
hope they answer some pretty good
questions for us uh really do so thank
you Mr Anderson for being here for
modding super appreciate it thanks for
everybody who is chatting thanks for the
super chats and if you were just
watching we super appreciate you as well
thanks for being here hope everybody
liked it and